[Music]
i mentioned that uh you've been in uh
two of the mission impossible
films of course star tom cruise i've met
tom cruise in person and i have to say
you meet a lot of people out in this
business and you think like oh yeah okay
they
that's that's an unusually good-looking
fellow that tom cruise is he not you
agree with disney here right yeah it
annoys me to be honest i find i i would
be slightly i get annoyed at him on set
because we were shooting in dubai it's
very hot there and you know for
continuity to say you can't have sweat
marks on your shirt so between takes
you'd sort of undress and i used to tell
him just put it back on will you tom you
know what i mean it was a distress
physique you were distracted by his body
he's 48 well he was then i don't know
what he's now probably 49 it was a year
ago
that was quick it was good yeah yeah
yeah
uh
but he's in such good shape i mean he's
he is in such good shape and he
he that he's an absolute sort of movie
machine you know i mean he dedicates
himself he hung off the tallest building
in the world for you
camera three you know because it means
something to him that the audience see
him doing it and not a cgi sprite or a
stunt man you know right and and yes
he's sickeningly good looking but
you got to love him yeah much clearer
you fell in love with him i did
i did i sometimes like if i get it
because i'm obviously in the uk we're on
different time
we're behind ahead of you uh so if i get
behind us since coming in so
yes
human rights but not health care not
health care
uh
i i sometimes if i get an email from tom
which i will occasionally do and we're
just going to bed and my wife's like
will you turn the light on no it's tom i
can't i can't
i've got to reply
i love him
were you surprised because uh when your
career was first starting out in the uk
did you ever imagine you're going to be
in these uh mission impossible films i
mean i know you had ambitions but these
are these
mega action
pictures was this something that was a
possibility no because you feel like i
don't know i was making shaun of the
dead was a very low budget british film
we never knew it would would even travel
over here let alone become popular and
and you know all that happened was that
jj abrams who is a fantastic director
and now friend saw sean of the dead said
hey let's get him in mission impossible
three and then that led to star trek and
you know it it wasn't uh
i didn't like win a golden ticket out of
a chocolate bar it was just quite a
simple
i wish i had
that's disappointing
i want to believe that everyone from
your country wins a willy wonka ticket
every hollywood actor every hollywood
actor a british hollywood actor has is
here because of a special golden ticket
why can't that happen
why can't it happen no i wish it did